il a plaidé coupable et demandé pardon
un soldat russe de 21 ans est jugé
devant le tribunal de kiev pour avoir
abattu un civils non armés il risque la
prison à vie il est le premier soldat
russe à être jugé pour crimes de guerre
depuis le début de l'invasion russe un
procès alors que la guerre fait toujours
rage des experts mettent en garde contre
une politisation de la procédure on
retrouve gulliver craag notre
correspondant à à kiev comment ce procès
est il suivi par la population
ukrainienne
alors d'abord je pense qu'il convient de
souligner que la une de l'actualité en
ukraine ça reste toujours la situation
sur la ligne de front les combats dans
le débat c'est les soldats qui sont
sortis d'ostal à marioupol mais tout de
même ce procès a suscité un vif intérêt
des médias il aa du été transférés vers
un autre tribunal vers une autre salle
pour qu'il y ait de la place pour que
les journalistes puissent rentrer j'ai
entendu quelques critiques un peu amer
de la part des ukrainiens entendant ses
réserves exprimées par certains experts
sur la possibilité d'une pousse
politisation de ce procès et sur le fait
que cela a été organisé relativement
vite moins de trois mois après les faits
le défendue et dont le tribunal et le
verdict est attendu à l'un des prochains
les ukrainiens 10ème et depuis combien
d'années on nous critique parce que
notre système de justice ne fonctionne
pas été trop lents et maintenant on nous
critique parce qu'on va trop vite
clairement il y a eu un souci de la part
de la cour et je pense de tous ceux qui
ont été impliqués dans l'organisation de
ce procès de montrer à quel point les
procédures sont respectées et notamment
à quel point le défendant a droit à un
procès à un avocat qui a vraiment
défendu sa position aujourd'hui à
l'avocat de vadim chessy marines et
soldats russes accusés à plaidoyer de
manière assez convaincant je dirais en
tout cas il a mis beaucoup de temps à
construire son argument pour essayer de
plaidoyer pour que vadim chessy marine
soit à quitter malgré le fait qu'il ait
plaidé coupable il notait la pression
qu'il y avait sur ce jeune soldat de la
part des autres soldats russes qui était
dans la voiture depuis laquelle ils
attiraient avec lui
l'avocat disait vadim si marine crédit
non pas seulement la possibilité que ce
civile puisse nuire à sa sécurité il
s'est avéré seulement après que le civil
ne faisait absolument rien pour informer
les forces armées mais aussi ils avaient
peur des ses propres compagnons qui
étaient dans la voiture je vous rappelle
vadim chez ses marines et un jeune
soldat il a 21 ans et dans chez les
ukrainiens à qui j'ai parlé il est
beaucoup d'opinions divergentes con
quand t'as combien de sympathie est ce
qu'on peut avoir envers ce jeune homme
merci beaucoup de l'hiver craag merci à
vous en direct de kiev et puis on vient
de l'apprendre les défenseurs